electromagnetic phenomena The Havana
syndrome things like that are there
pertinent aspects that we could learn
about Consciousness either from the
claimed or real evidence has been
presented for electromagnetic
stimulation I would bet that Havana
syndrome is some kind of effect on
microtubules it could be microwave
gigahertz we know microtypus resonated
gigahertz it might be radio waves
megahertz but if you over resonate
something like the bridge it's going to
shatter and I think that's exactly what
happened and in fact concussion in
concussion your microtubules get
fractured and broken and that's been
well proven so it's a lot like a
post-concussion syndrome